the reality is most of us could use a
little less screen time and a little
more face-to-face so today I'm gonna
give you 10 tips to put more life in
your living but first shout-out to Ahmed
who deleted all of his social media apps
and survived this video has two parts
first I'm going to share with you some
ways to help you ease into healthier
phone habits and at the end I'll share
some more challenging tips for those of
you who want to live on the wild side so
number one avoid using your cell phone
when you're sharing a meal with others I
mentioned in my videos six reasons why I
do not own a TV that my family has a
rule where we do not allow cell phone
use at the dinner table or really any
meal when we eat as a family we value
that time it's time to catch up share
ideas laugh and enjoy each other's
company
number two if you're eating out with
someone don't place your phone on the
table it subliminally sets a barrier
kind of like a message saying I'm
waiting for a call or I'm wanting to
check on something
it's like looking at your watch when
you're having a conversation you're done
yet
number three this is kind of a personal
one to me but please do not use your
phone at the register I used to be a
cashier and some people would be on
their phone the entire time some
wouldn't even say a single word to me
throughout the whole process not only is
that rude but all humans deserve respect
and dignity even cashiers so my tip for
this is if you're on the phone kindly
tell that person to wait just a moment
while you pay for something that way you
won't have to divide your attention
between two people and no one will get
hurt
and all of these three tips the main
takeaway is to be mindful of the people
in the world around you there is a world
outside your phone thanks for listening
to me
it's been really hard for me lately and
it's the first time that I've talked to
someone about it you're really sorry
were you talking to me I had my
headphones in tip number four no phones
on the bed don't allow yourself to use a
phone on the bed because you'll end up
checking on just one more thing and
you'll never go to sleep and also the
blue light emitted from your phone tells
your brain that it's daytime and it
makes it even harder for you to fall
asleep
even after turning your phone off and
number five when you actually go to bed
put distance between you and your phone
so that you actually have to physically
get out of bed to get to it this will
help you by placing a barrier to make it
less likely that you will actually get
up to go get it but an added bonus is if
it is your alarm clock it's also much
more likely that you're gonna get out of
bed shut that thing off and if after all
of this you still get out of bed to get
to your phone and check it in the middle
of the night consider putting a bedtime
alarm on it number six was a big one for
me turn off notifications five years ago
when I had social media this one was a
big one for me because I just had to
check that little message icon to see
what it was all about it is addicting it
releases dopamine which tells your brain
that it's pleasurable and so you need
more of this if you have trouble with
notifications turn them off it can help
easier temptation and tip number seven
okay this is a weird one but don't use
your cell phone in the bathroom I mean
can we not live without our phones for
just a few minutes what do you think
about this one okay so I shared seven
small changes with you now let's get to
the big stuff cold turkey style number
one delete social media I told you these
were a bit more challenging if you're
struggling to put your phone down
chances are social media might have
something to do with it if you need some
motivation as to why you should consider
quitting social media check out my video
six reasons why I quit social media
I haven't had social media in five years
and I don't need it you can survive and
thrive without it the next one
delete gaming apps that you spend the
most time on okay don't laugh but candy
crush was my addiction must crush
Candy's but seriously this game kept me
up at night because I just had to get to
the next level if this sounds like you
toss them you don't need them they're
depriving you of sleep and depriving you
of activities that could be a lot more
productive and more fulfilling and while
you're at it if you want even more of a
challenge then do like a spring cleaning
through all of your apps by asking
yourself if each one of them actually
brings value to your life or if it's
actually useful I mean is candy crush
really a necessity and the last one
replaced that extra time with something
that's more productive that brings you
joy my diet is much healthier than it
was 10 years ago
but it never felt like I was missing out
on anything because instead of focusing
on what I couldn't have I focused on
adding and having more of healthier
choices and the same applies to habits
in general when you miss mindlessly
scrolling through your phone or you're
bored and you're tempted to pull it out
just because have a list of things that
you can do instead that bring you joy
the point here is to trick your brain to
release that dopamine with other things
it can be exercised listening to music
or doing a hobby that you enjoy there
was a world before phones so be creative
and think of other activities that you
can do to replace that screen time but
be sure to share them in the comments so
that we can all learn from each other
and for sticking to the end my bonus tip
for you is beware of FOMO this is huge
when it comes to eliminating unhealthy
tech habits because billions of dollars
are invested into the production of
Bones apps and advertisements that are
meant to keep us glued I was asked what
if I missed an important phone call and
all I was doing was eating yummy cake
great question number one why should I
be concerned and not answering my phone
if it is a life and death call then I'm
probably not the person to call this
should probably be calling 9-1-1
and number two if it actually is that
important they would probably call more
than once and something you can do to
help you with this FOMO is to go ahead
and let your friends and family know
that during next time or ex activity you
won't be answering your phone
that way you won't be worried that
you're going to miss an emergency and
they won't be worried that something is
wrong and point number three my last one
for this question I work with dying
patients for a living and this has
changed my mentality in so many ways the
small details in life are worth enjoying
yes even a piece of yummy but
unnecessary cake if I'm gonna do
something enjoyable like eating cake I
want to do it mindfully and actually
enjoy it so long story short yeah I may
not answer my phone to eat some yummy
cake that's all for today guys if you
have your own ideas please share them in
the comments and if you like this video
don't forget to Like and subscribe so
that you won't miss out on my weekly
videos I thank you so much for watching
and I can't wait to see you in the next
one
[Music]
okay now I want something who's with me